[Music]
it's an instinctive feeling
the horse profs together
good people will fight if we lead them
[Music]
people keep telling me they know me
no one does
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we did
[Applause]
you're coming together
[Applause]
is your undoing
[Applause]
what are we doing there are three bill
taking one last look sir but my friends
and some to fear the destiny of the Jedi
[Music]
your destiny
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the force will be with you always
[Music]
a king there's no friends
holy followers at fault in your chapter
my life is done this Prince I spent my
days drinking clowning
now I find myself the king choose your
steps wisely here brother they have
their own kingdoms behind their eyes I
need men around me I can trust
you know my friend I will come with you
now you will be wash over vitals here
the different King France is taunting us
they were my father's enemies not mine
the screams of young men
that led me to sleep at night you will
not topple this king henry v of england
you so underestimate are you ready for
awaits us
or is bloody and slowly this is hope
this is form do you feel a sense of
achievement surrender to me
King of England are you scared already I
can feel the weight of this crown I wear
[Music]
and initiate sequencing
memories are made of this what is this
place
I'm sorry to be the one to tell you this
but you got yourself killed at rst we'd
rebuild the most important assets in the
US military soldiers like yourself
you're the first who we've successfully
managed to bring back but improved
enhanced with the technology in your
veins you have an army inside you that
will not only make you stronger you will
heal you instantly for a
now tell me do you remember anything
where you going
I got unfinished business
find the man who murdered my wife and
killer
[Music]
it's not good all right sundown
and initiate sequence okay who is the
next target for elimination
these are literally tell me do you
remember anything
do I know you guys I don't think so
I've been manipulating you
what you think is really sometimes ain't
and initiate sequence
[Music]
you control me for
you sure about that
revenge is what makes a man my human
exceptional
you know nothing about men like me
[Music]
is absolutely fantastic
I feel like I just heard this electric
assembly people
we are gathered here today to join B and
Thomas in holy matrimony you're taking
this so well he's a good man you hated
this guy
we've grown very close welcoming a new
parent not that close so father know
you're not my father
sorry it's really the rabbit story I
just wrote it down look I hate that I'm
the face of this Morty what I knew Peter
that depends who's asking Peter told you
he has it in for me he was talking to
all of us I'm talking to you Peter
specifically stay out of trouble if
that's who they think I am maybe I'd be
better off without them
[Music]
oh come on
[Music]
or you look goody-goody you return me
I'm know pretty good eat apparently I'm
a fatty fatty is your name Peter rabbits
yeah I was best friends with you dad my
name is Barnabas you're a fierce bad
rabbit just like where are the rabbits
back in their burrows snug as a bug in a
rug
spread out
[Music]
join them early I'm speeding up a little
and that's what adults shouldn't do kid
stuff
being a street dog isn't so bad at all
he's a Chan I'm free to be whoever I
want to be walk wherever I want to walk
hey hi are you two UH twins I'm her
husband pal
ah ha eat whatever I want to keep he's a
trip you know what fine
just remember I got this the
old-fashioned way I stole it
snob hell there we go I got my color let
me just take a little guess here you're
the center of your people's universe
right you could say that well that's
basically all over now you're about to
be replaced replace me I don't think so
lady this is Lulu
when the baby moves in the dog moves out
[Music]
help me get this thing off I'm sorry
this is not awkward at all this way
totally safe I'm not gonna do that
keep it crazy you wanna laugh
[Applause]
what is this place
and a great big world out there
with no fence around it
[Music]
every day could be an adventure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
daddy we have a few questions
where were you the night Lily bridges
disappeared
Lucy this is Lilly Lilly Lucy fly so how
long have you been in Japan three weeks
now too weird no everyone stares at you
it's like being famous
some people get addicted to those you
are not normal either are you
No so let's not pretend to be you
photograph everything of course
do you have a boyfriend thank you so
cute cute oh he's gorgeous he's like
obsessed with you why do you say that I
know man she's a piece of work that one
it's like you only want to exist then
she moves on to someone else it's like
you were never even there what do you
say potato come on
we have something no one else could
share
don't you know that I do something wrong
I know what I'm feeling and it's not
right at all
you must trust
Oh
like something really Bad's gonna happen
this place is beautiful
it's like the perfect holiday card it's
no words a lot it's like this space of
whether you can do a lot worse than this
place trust me
tell her that you like her
I noticed I was five years old it's not
easy you just have to tell her you want
the same relationship plus bowling hey
what's up I'm up good see you downstairs
when you find a bra
Christmas Eve bash come one come all
boom
he's gonna break up with you you would
have to be the dumbest human being on
earth to do that like to dumber than the
people who blow on ice cream before they
eat it I have a thing have you ever been
with someone and you stay up until like
4:00 a.m. just talking about everything
and you're just like I can't believe I
get to exist at the same time as you
know but like I'm really happy for you
I realized that life is just a bunch of
stuff you can't control but is that a
bad thing
do you think I happen good but anything
[Music]
and she's hooking up with them no
they're not hooking up yeah
[Music]
think your nipples bleeding
[Music]
what I love about Nicole she is a mother
who plays really plays what I love about
Charlie he loves being a dad he loves
all the things you're supposed to hate
like waking up at night she knows when
to push me and when to leave me alone
he never lets other people keep him from
what he wants to do no it's not easy for
her to close a captain he's incredible
Nev she's brave he's brilliant
she's very competitive so I'll tell
Charlie what's happening and Cassie knew
then hand him the envelope I just get
nervous
can you unser we mean like take it back
Charlie and I are getting a divorce line
you can't be friends with him anymore
[Applause]
you know most people in my business
because transactions to them I like to
think of it was people okay good you
remind me of myself on my second
marriage we're gonna do together is
telling you were story you dye your hair
again well this is me we all like it is
it shortened
I prefer longer but how are you doing I
never really come along for myself I was
just feeding his aliveness
I'll never get to really be his parent
together he needs to know that I fought
for him
[Music]
it's not as simple as not being in love
anymore eventually it'll be the two of
you having to figure dis help
[Music]
together
if we start from a place of reasonable
and they start from a place of crazy
when we settled will be somewhere
between reasonable and crazy
and ask you a question why did the CIA
torture people lie about it and hide it
from history after 9/11 everyone was
scared scared it might happen again
we need to stop attacks in the future
and we are in whatever business it takes
to get the job done
find out exactly what they did one
detainee and he waterboarded him 183
times if it works why do you need to do
it 183 times maybe one the report comes
out people will finally see that they
claim they saved lives but what they
really did was make it impossible to
prosecute mass murderer because if what
we did to him ever came out the court of
law the case is over
the guy planned 9/11 the CIA sends a
program wouldn't cause lasting harm so
how long is go Rahman gonna be dead for
this question isn't about our enemies
it's about us I would like us to be more
than the country that did the report I'd
like us to be the country that made it
public
we will not allow this to be covered up
the report radar coming soon so you're
vacationing in Zambia huh mm-hmm
let me guess you're from LA New York yes
I take it mr. Conrad won't be joining us
two days ago he told me that our
marriage was over Oh two hours ago I
landed here on what was supposed to be
our second honeymoon by myself a lot of
people come here to get lost so they can
be found again
thank you Yoda oh you're coming on this
too
yep Tara Collinsworth in case you want
to write my name down on a complaint
form oh yeah the pilot we're flying over
the largest game reserve in Africa hang
on
gonna make a stop stay in the plane
hook him back
poachers cut the mama for tusks we don't
do some to help that baby we built in
two days I want to help didn't see that
one coming house first well I took a
little detour it's gonna be okay it'll
be touch and go for a while but we will
do our best
I'm in this place surrounded by wild
animals hey New York oh sorry
umm you are coming home right this year
it's gonna be Christmas in Africa what
is Christmas in Africa well I can't
speak for the whole continent but here
at the elephant orphanage they celebrate
all week and there is no shopping
involved I'm really starting to worry
I've got to go back home and I don't
know what I'm supposed to do with myself
maybe you're doing it here this is how
it starts we meet an elephant and so
begins the relationship of a lifetime
take good care of my elephant he and I
were just friends mmm-hmm said you
didn't get to go your fancy five-star
Safari let me take you on one with
little stars like three I could more
like two I haven't seen you that someone
in a long time if I have learned
anything it's not get too attached never
meant to stay this long you're falling
in love huh
with Africa you know what that is what
this will tell that is definitely not
new South African mistletoe
[Music]
[Music]